MANOJ GUNTI: Hello, everyone.
Thank you so much for tuning in.
My name is Manoj Gunti.
I am the product marketing
manager for Google Cloud's
Apigee API Management Platform.
And today, I'm joined by
Mudit Purwar from T-Mobile.
Hi, Mudit.
MUDIT PURWAR: Thank you, Manoj.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Mudit Purwar,
and I'm a principal engineer
in API Center for Enablement,
leading the API development
engineering team, along
with driving the CI/CD
and self-service automation
tools initiatives
for API program at T-Mobile.
MANOJ GUNTI: Welcome, Mudit.
So in this session, we want
to explain and show you
a live demo of
how you can extend
Google's industry-leading AI
and ML technologies to your API
programs.
For many years, we
had the opportunity
to work with customers
across the globe
and across industries.
Throughout this journey,
we have observed
that the role of APIs
and API management
has been continuously evolving.
What used to be just an agent
for accessing various systems
is now actually an agent for
driving digital transformation
programs.
While APIs continue to be built
and consumed by developers,
IT leadership, marketing, and
other line of business owners
have started looking
at APIs as something
beyond just a
piece of technology
to drive real digital
transformation programs.
And when you align APIs with
your digital experiences,
it also creates an upstream
impact on the value chain.
When your core business
critical applications
are powered by APIs,
imagine what impact
down times, performance
degradations, or even security
incidents can have on your
customers and partners.
Therefore, API
operations becomes
extremely critical to ensure
a connected and seamless
digital experience is delivered
to all of the stakeholders.
However, operations teams
are under immense pressure.
As a Sys Admin, how do I ensure
my APIs are up and running
and performing as expected?
When there is an
issue, how do I quickly
identify the root cause?
And I want to do all of this
without getting distracted
by a false alert noise.
As a SecOps person, I want
to ensure my APIs adhere
to compliance requirements.
I want to protect my
sensitive data from abuse
and quickly diagnose
security incidents.
And the good news is,
as you build and scale
your API programs, there
is a goldmine of API data
that's collected across
the entire API value
chain, all the way from
your backend targets
to the front end apps.
And this data can be leveraged
to solve these problems.
Google Cloud's Apigee
API management platform
applies industry-leading
AI and ML models
to harness the
power of your data.
With features like API
monitoring, anomaly detection,
security reporting,
and bot protection,
you can now ensure that your
APIs are always available,
secure, and performing
as expected.
With that, let me
turn it over to Mudit
to talk about
T-Mobile's API journey
and how they have put AI
and ML-powered capabilities
into practice.
Over to you, Mudit.
MUDIT PURWAR: Thank you, Manoj.
We at T-Mobile are on
a journey to change
the wireless experience
of our customers.
In today's digital age of
mobile-ware, artificial
intelligence, machine
learning, internet of things,
changing the customer
experience is
impossible without leveraging
the power of the APIs
across the digital value chain.
Hence, let's reflect back
on our API journey so far.
We started with Apigee API
Gateway back in 2015 with two
dedicated API teams
developing APIs
to expose legacy services for
a new radically simplified
frontline application.
In 2017, to bring some
cohesiveness among the growing
API teams, Proxy Gen, a
homegrown API development tool,
was launched.
It would take the API contract
or the [INAUDIBLE] as an input
and generate the Apigee
API proxy bundle,
check the code into the source
code management repository,
launch the CI/CD pipelines,
and deploy the Apigee proxy
into Apigee Edge.
It was an instant hit
with the API developer
community at T-Mobile.
API Center for Enablement
was launched in 2018
to address the growing
challenges with the API program
that was gradually emerging.
Same year, we launched a suite
of API first development tools
to enable the domain teams
to self-serve themselves
for any need on the
Apigee API platform.
And here we are in 2020 with
80-plus business domain teams
developing APIs within T-Mobile.
Together, they have produced
1,300-plus API proxies,
resulting in over 9 billion
transactions per month.
Let's look at some of the API
operational challenges that
come with this kind of growth.
Here are some of the
challenges we continually
face every day in the
API operation space.
And some of these might
resonate with your company's API
operations as well.
Securing and protecting APIs
from external and internal
bad actors, bot traffic,
denial-of-service attacks,
broken authentication,
and so on and so forth,
and trying to continually
maintain a secure posture
to have a seamless digital
experience for our customers.
Observability into unexpected
and unforeseen API runtime
issues and contextual
information about those
issues is a key challenge
to improve the API
availability and performance.
API platform scalability to
handle the sudden traffic burst
during our Un-Carrier
move announcements,
like our latest Un-Carrier
move, Scam Shield,
and promotional events,
like Black Friday holiday
season, et cetera.
On a similar note,
capacity planning
to support new innovative
growth that we foresee
beyond wireless, like
our banking service,
T-Mobile Money, our TV
service, T-Vision, and others.
And then streamlining the API
consumer and partner onboarding
process to access T-Mobile APIs
to improve the API consumer
and partner experience
and agility.
AI and ML have
definitely helped us
in addressing some
of these challenges.
AI and ML features, like API
monitoring and Apigee Sense,
have definitely empowered
our everyday API operations
by covering our blind side
for unforeseen API traffic
and performance issues, which
could go undetected and cause
severe API
availability incidents
and impact the
business negatively.
Anomaly detection
and API operations
by applying AI and
ML models is aligned
with T-Mobile's
observability objectives,
like proactively monitoring
the systems and APIs,
detecting issues prior
to any negative impact
on the business, and developing
automated capabilities where
possible.
Alerting and notification
combined with anomaly detection
or real-time traffic
and performance issues
has improved our
team's productivity
and significantly reduced the
MTTD, mean time to diagnose,
API incidents.
With the added
suggested operator
controls in the form of
predetermined resolution
labels or any issues has notably
reduced the MTTR, mean time
to resolution, of
any API incident.
Let's look at a demo on how AI
and ML have empowered our API
operations at T-Mobile.
Let's check out some of the
Apigee's built-in AI and ML
features in real time and how
these features are assisting
in keeping T-Mobile APIs
available and performant
for a seamless
digital experience
of T-Mobile customers.
When you log into
Apigee Edge, this
is how the landing
page looks like.
You can get to all the
observability related features
under the Analyze tab.
As a DevOps engineer, I visit
the API Monitoring Overview
dashboard quite frequently.
This dashboard provides
me with a quick summary
about the runtime telemetry of
all the API proxies deployed
in the production environment.
For the purposes
of this demo, we
will be using one of our
development environments,
wherein hopefully you will
not see a lot of broken stuff.
As you can see in
this dashboard,
we get a summary information
about a given API environment,
total traffic and transactions
per second, overall average
error rate percentage,
top API proxy response
P99 latency value, and total
number of recent alerts.
It also provides top three
API proxies with highest value
in each metric category.
So this dashboard
provides a DevOps
engineer a pretty good overview
of any potential runtime issues
with any API proxy.
Now let's move on
to the Events tab
to check if there have been
any recent alerts triggered
or any new anomalies detected.
Looks like we will have to
go a little bit back in time
to see any alerts and anomaly.
Here you go.
So the Alert tab shows all
the recent triggered alerts
based on the predefined
conditions set by us.
The Anomaly tab
shows all the events
that deviate from the
normal behavioral pattern
at the Apigee region,
organization, and environment
level.
These deviations, as
well as the severity,
is detected by applying the
built-in AI and ML models
to the historical API data.
The cool thing about the anomaly
is the contextual information
it provides with respect
to environment name, API
proxy name, target,
fault code region,
and the time of the trigger.
For a DevOps engineer,
this contextual information
about an anomaly is really
critical and important,
as it significantly reduces
the overall MTTD, mean time
to diagnose, and MTTR,
mean time to resolution,
for any unexpected
and unforeseen issues
within our APIs which
might be in our blind side.
And the amazing thing
about this feature
is that we do not have to do
anything to set all this up.
It comes by default
and is built in.
So based on this
contextual information,
if a DevOps engineer
decides to dive
in deeper into the
anomaly, he or she
can drill down into
the anomaly, and it
will take them into the
Investigate page or the tab.
So let's investigate
one of the anomalies.
Just looking at the
anomaly details on the top,
looks like this
anomaly was detected
due to unreasonably high number
of 504 response code in the API
flow, which started at
around 3:17 in the afternoon.
Let's look at why the API
is returning the 504 error
response to the clients.
Now, I have various ways
and different dimensions
that I can find the root
cause about this issue.
Let's try to determine the
fourth source in the API flow
by looking at
different dimensions.
I would want to look
at the false source
at this point in time.
So I'll go select that
dimension from the dropdown.
And as we can see
in the API flow,
it is pretty obvious
that the target endpoint
is the problematic area.
So let's dig in further by
clicking on the target cell.
Here, we can see
the suspected cause
determined by the ML model.
This can be attributed to
the fault code, which clearly
states that the error
response code is being
written by the backend service.
Also, there are details for the
impacted clients, API clients,
and the target endpoints
that this API is dependent
upon and is at fault
for this anomaly.
Now, if we want to look at any
specific transactional level
information, we can do so
by going into View Logs.
This view provides us
into specific details
about each transaction, like the
request URI, which is basically
the URI being invoked
by the API client
along with the request
message ID, what
is the status code,
response time, [INAUDIBLE]
source, and other details about
the client and the transaction.
Next, I can do additional
things with this anomaly,
like creating an alert
based off this anomaly.
So let's quickly create an
alert based off this anomaly.
We'll have to hit this
button, Create Alert Tab,
and we'll have to come up with
an alert name of our choice,
provide the description
to it, what type of alert.
If we want to base this
alert based off this anomaly,
we can leave it at anomaly.
And then alter the
condition if we choose to
or let it remain the same
as detected by the anomaly.
And we have to select the alert
notification type we want,
like email notification or Slack
or a PagerDuty notification.
Once you have filled
out this form,
we just have to save this, and
we have a pre-configured alert
for a given anomaly condition
for future proactive
notifications.
So let me share some
sample alert notifications.
Here is one email
alert notification
and how it looks like.
It provides us information
like the timestamp
of the trigger, org name, alert
name, summary of the alert,
and details
regarding the alerts,
like the condition, trigger
value, proxy region, et cetera.
And it also provides embedded
links to directly view
the event in Apigee Edge.
This is how a sample Slack
notification looks like.
It provides us the
name of the alert,
organization name,
special violation details,
like the target latency,
proxy name, region,
condition information,
so on and so forth.
It also provides us web links
as well to view the anomaly
or the alert details
directly into the Events
tab of Apigee Edge.
So let's go back.
Now, I can do further
things, like I
can create a report based
off this anomaly to look
for any additional dimensions
for further analysis,
or for an RCA, or for
management reporting needs.
We are really impressed by
the API monitoring feature,
as it has helped mitigate
latency and network
issues in the past, resulting
in increased API availability,
along with improved
performance of our APIs.
Next, let's see
how collections can
be really useful in
making the most out
of these AI and ML features.
Collections are group of API
proxies, targets, developer
apps based on the organization
choice of dimension.
We at T-Mobile have collections
based off business domain APIs,
which helps us in setting
up appropriate alert
configurations and
threshold values
for the same group of APIs.
Next, I want to
move on to security.
Security is one of
the single biggest
challenge that most of
the digital enterprises
are trying to solve.
And it never gets easier, with
ever-evolving newer threats
surfacing every day.
In the Security Reporting
Overview dashboard,
we have information with respect
to northbound API traffic
for all the given
environments, and it
provides further information
regarding the API proxies,
taking active traffic out
of the total API deployed,
total number of [INAUDIBLE]
deployed in a given
environment, total
traffic, and the percent
exchanged in traffic.
It also provides the API client
traffic composition by region.
Since this is one of our
development environment,
and most of our developers are
based in the US West Coast,
hence, we can see the
corresponding traffic
competition being higher
in the US West region.
Let's move on to the
Runtime dashboard, which
provides us more
specific and detailed
runtime information
about the API proxies.
It provides information
about the API proxy traffic,
percentage change in
traffic, and percentage
of traffic on non-HTTPS
or non-secured code,
and the total number
of API clients
in working or
accessing this API.
And if I want to look for
the details into API proxy,
it provides us a
visualized graph
for the HTTPS and non-HTTPS
API access protocols.
And then it also provides
further data points
with respect to
developer apps, which
will host and target
endpoints that this API
proxy is dependent on.
Let's move on to the
configuration of the API
proxies.
This particular
dashboard provides
us insight into the API
proxy's security configuration
and policy
composition, as well as
providing information about
the virtual host definitions
as well.
So different
categories of policies
include the traffic
management, security,
and extension policies, as
well as reusable piece of code
in the form of shared flows.
So virtual host is a
definition in API proxy
which determines how
the API clients--
or on which protocol
the API clients
are going to access the APIs.
If we want to dig deeper
into specific security policy
details that are
part of API proxy,
we can click on
API Proxy, and we
can see specific policy names
that are part of this given API
proxy.
And then if there are some
security policy standards that
have been established
by our API program,
we can evaluate each and every
proxy against those standards
to see whether these APIs
are in compliance or not.
So this dashboard is very
helpful in a quick glance
on the security posture of our
runtime API configurations.
So all of this data that is
visualized on this dashboard
is also available via APIs
for the security organization
to integrate this data with the
custom dashboards and reporting
tools.
Finally, we're going to
talk about user activity.
As a User Activity dashboard
has individual user identifying
information, which
I cannot display,
therefore I have screenshots
for the User Activity Details
dashboard.
User Activity dashboard
provides insight
into the user access and
their access behavior
at on the Apigee Edge UI
or via the Management APIs,
as well as change
in user activity
over the period of time
and what type of data
they are accessing
and percentage
of potentially sensitive
operations they have performed.
If we identify any suspicious
activity by a user,
we can drill down further on
all the activities and actions
performed by a particular user,
like the resources they have
accessed and what
action they have taken
on those particular resources.
To recap, security
reporting feature
provides us with relevant
data points and matrix
to evaluate whether API
proxies are adhering
to security policies and
configuration requirements set
forth by the organization's
digital security team.
Lastly, realizing the value
of these productive AI and ML
features is the key to have
highly available and performant
APIs for any API program.
Next, let's review some real
world business outcomes,
wherein these features were
immensely valuable for our API
DevOps and [INAUDIBLE] Team.
Bot traffic is estimated to
be 40% of overall internet
traffic.
And out of those, 20%
is bad bot traffic.
Speaking of bad bot traffic,
one of the anomalies
we had was certain surge
in traffic to our auth
API during off-business
hours, which is odd.
Upon diagnosing the
issue, we found out
that some bad
actors overseas were
trying to harvest the
access tokens from the auth
API using bots,
specifically bad bots.
As this was a major
security incident,
we moved fast to
remedy the issue.
Coupled with Apigee Sense
and other [INAUDIBLE] tools,
we were able to
successfully block
the bot traffic very quickly.
Next, network latencies can
cause substantial degradation
in service and negatively
impact the SLAs.
Another anomaly detected
was network latency
in API response times.
API transactions were making
coast-to-coast round trip
to our East Coast data center,
even though the traffic
originated in US West region,
adding substantial latency
and negatively impacting
our customers' digital web
experience.
Upon diagnosing the issue,
the major cloud provider
unconsciously made changes to
their networking routing logic.
To elevate the
issue [INAUDIBLE],,
we made a few routing logic
changes in our API flow.
But ultimately,
the cloud provider
was able to permanently fix the
network issue on their side.
New product launches
and new promotions,
like our latest Scam Shield
Uncarrier move are big events
and can bring huge surge
in traffic to our websites.
Next anomaly detected was a
sudden burst in API traffic
for T-Vision APIs when
they were launched.
We expected a surge but not
the extent of 700% increase.
Since this was one of
the SaS environments,
Apigee Support
Team at Google was
contacted to check up on
auto-scale capabilities
of the Apigee runtime competence
to handle the additional load.
All of these incidents
were detected
by API monitoring, which
is a testament to AI and ML
capabilities for automated
monitoring and alerting,
along with the
ability to dig deeper
into an anomaly or incident in
real time to diagnose the issue
and find resolution for it.
To conclude, AI and
ML have significantly
transformed the business
of operating APIs,
and in near future, using
advanced predictive analytics,
the ability to predict
incidents before they
impact customer and
probably self-resolve
will elevate it
to the next level.
Thank you, and
back to you, Manoj.
MANOJ GUNTI: That's awesome.
Thank you, everyone,
for tuning in.
Hope you have got a good
insight on how you can apply
AI and ML to your API programs.
Feel free to post any
questions or comments
that you may have
in the Q&A Module,
and we'll be more than
happy to address them.
Once again, thank you
so much for tuning in,
and have a very nice day.